le syndrome d'lander vous connaissez
Christophe Lambert bah oui non dans
Islander le héros est immortel attends
du coup le syndrome d'lander ça veut
dire qu'on est non le syndrome d'ylander
ça veut pas dire qu'on est immortel ça
veut dire qu'on vieillit plus lentement
attends mais c'est trop bien de pas
vieillir ah moi je veux bien ah bah si
ah bah ben non tenez ce jeune coréen en
pyjama là vous lui donnez quel âge 12 13
ans Max perdu yum Yung Shin c'est son
nom il a 26 ans et il mesure 1,63 parce
que le syndrome d'ylander ça ralentit le
vieillissement mais ça ralentit aussi la
croissance et puis il aime faire la fête
il aime danser il aime aller en boîte de
nuit avec ses amis qui ont le même âge
que lui mais pour lui c'est pas
forcément facile d'être crédible c'est
même déjà pas forcément très facile de
rentrer en boîte j'imagine bah c'est pas
vraiment une bonne nouvelle de paraître
la moitié de son âge pas à cet âge là en
tout cas alors aujourd'hui yomyung Shin
il a 34 ans et la bonne nouvelle c'est
que en dehors de son retard de
croissance et de puberté les médecins
estiment que son syndrome a eu aucun
autre effet sur sa santé par contre
personne comprend encore le pourquoi et
le comment les médecins cherchent encore
des explications